[Music]
honey salt has been a local's favorite
for years and they now have a variety of
special nights here to tell us all about
it is executive chef sterling buckley
welcome buddy thank you how long have
you been with honey salt i've been with
honey salt for just about a year now so
these special nights that we have what
are some of these nights that you guys
have going on uh so we we do first of
all we're doing on the january 25th
we're doing birds in bourbon which is a
special menu where we're doing uh our
pairings with different birds uh whether
it's pheasant or squale or chicken or
turkey duck and we're just kind of
making a really creative meal with
collaborating with freight ranch and
freight ranch is is a nevada born and
raised whiskey company or bourbon
company it is that's awesome that's
awesome and uh what are you making right
here and how does that tie into one of
your special nights so we also do uh pot
pie tuesdays
and uh we do a lobster in a chicken pot
pie so what i got right now is the
lobster pot pie i love the sound of that
pot pie tuesday night is that the only
thing on the menu on pot pie tuesday
nights uh actually the first so we do a
appetizer course so you could get it as
a like as a tasting menu okay and what
we do is we have um
we have uh ribs as a first course or the
kale salad as the first course and then
you can uh do the either lobster or
chicken pot pie beautiful beautiful so
which one you make it again the lobster
one we are doing the lobster pot pie i'm
just gonna
dust the rim here so it could stick and
how would you as you're making this this
lobster popeye how would you describe
the atmosphere of honey salted honey
salt is very much so uh it feels like
you're in the owner's home this uh kim
and elizabeth it feels like you're in
their home so you'll see a lot of like
pictures of of them in the family and uh
even some of us are there's pictures of
some of us that work there in their
pictures of us and it's just very feels
like you're in their home and that's
what we try to do we try to make it like
you're there in our in our home and we
want to take care of you and make it fun
for you and we want to treat you like
your family i was gonna say you guys do
that if anyone's been to honeysuckle you
walk into that restaurant and you feel
like you're visiting your aunt's house
or something you feel like family when
you walk into honeysuckle that's why you
love it so much you put some salt on top
of the popeye a little sea salt to
season it and then we're gonna go
straight into the oven with this and how
long does a pot pie cook for pot pie
usually takes about 20 minutes 25
minutes depending
on uh
on how your oven is you've already had
one cooking that's why it smells so good
in this video today because you guys
chef sterling is cooking here got about
a minute here once you bring that pot
pie out of the oven
now what what what do you pair with
popeye do you go to whiskey do you go
with a wine a beer what goes in the pot
pie well for me it would either be a
whisk or a beer just that guy but uh i
would say definitely definitely a nice a
nice uh solid beer would be perfect
would be perfect with this uh some a
nice light beer because it's already
really heavy sure tonight's light beer
would you would go really well with this
or uh for me i just like a straight shot
of whiskey with anything i mean that's
just that's how i roll it now it's
something the size that's that's that's
a lot of food right there this feeds a
family of fours is one person going to
sit down and eat this this is the one
that's a one person that's the one we're
eating that honeysuckle this is good yes
yes are you gonna pop it open or how do
we do this yes let's do it crack that
thing open
what's it eat cut a pot pie
oh now you just break right you go get
in there yo eat a medieval in there just
like that that looks kind of mix in the
crust because you want kind of like the
crust mix kind of like it's like one of
those things like getting a little soggy
you're super hot can i give it a shot
before we wrap it up here
thank you oh
might be a little hot what a gig i have
honey sauce oh that's hot honey sauce
cooking for us in the kitchen
let's try this roof
[Music]
whoa
that sauce is to die for right there
sterling that is some good sauce right
there thank you thank you so much i'll
put that back in there i want to share
that with everyone here at the station
sterling real quick the website for
everyone honeysalt.com awesome delicious
check out honey salt and jillian we'll
send it over to